hello everyone and welcome back to Ali
resa's race to the candidates tournament
he already defeated four very strong
opponents or rather two opponents but
two games each and now one remains
strong Ukrainian Grandmaster Sergey
Fedor graded
2546 but some 13 years ago he was almost
2700 So he is a he's a very strong
opponent to force two wins upon as Anish
also mentioned on the Twitter I said
that ala could have chosen maybe some
some lighter opposition uh but uh you
know you you have to win them all and if
he wins this with the black pieces he
will take he will overtake Wesley so in
the live ratings uh which means that he
can even abandon playing game six at all
but I guess most likely he will he will
play it uh but let's see what happen in
this one and then we are going to
discuss all of the possibilities so here
Serge has the white pieces and he opens
not that he plays Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to C5 uh ala goes for the Sicilian
Defense Knight F3 D6 and D4 for the open
Sicilian captures captures we have
Knight F6 Knight to C3 and A6 the Knight
of Sicilian the the most fighting
Sicilian if you will and H3 this is the
Adams attack and for those of you who
have been following my rapid leeches
games I've been using it uh there and
with some uh with some very good success
uh we have Pawn to E5 challenging the
Knight Knight D to E2 and now Pawn to H5
this is the move I hate the most when I
play with the wi pieces because if black
doesn't play this then once to advance
those Pawns
at the G5 um uh well all all depends on
how how you do it but yeah if you get G4
G5 in it can be a very nasty position
for black to play uh but it's still
perfectly fine so G3 here preparing to F
to the light Square Bishop Bishop to E7
and now Bishop to G2 is by far the most
common move here Bishop to E3 is what
Serge plays uh and now uh there are a
couple of games for Knight B to D7 was
played But Here pawn to B5 is a new move
so already as of move nine we have a
completely new game
uh and serge already goes for a very
nasty idea and that is Knight to D5 it's
a beautiful Square for the Knight and it
seems like he's blundering a pawn here
but not really if you capture this Pawn
uh then you can go for something like
Bishop B6 attack the queen and also
Knight C7 to win The Rook or you don't
even have to do that you can just
counter it with Bishop to G2 and this is
game over for black to give you an
example even if you play F5 there's
Knight C3 and even if you trade here
let's say captures and captures uh and
close the position with E4 there's this
very nasty Queen to D5 and you cannot
save The Rook so also uh one of the nice
ideas on why to put the bishop on E3 uh
so here Knight B to D7 and now Knight E
to C3 we have Bishop to B7 and now
Bishop to G2 uh Rook to C8 nicely
developing and now Pawn to A4 as the
Knight on D5 controls the B4 Square so
you don't have to worry about B4 so
Knight captures on D5 we have Knight
captures Bishop captures and now uh
Queen Wing captures on D5 trying to
offer the C2 Pawn for the B5 Pawn uh but
that would uh be better for white as you
also have the a file to to lift your
Rook uh so here Pawn to B4 B it is a b
Capt on A4 the engine really likes but
it's sort of a move that um you don't
really play as a human uh B4 has the
downfall of uh if white finds Bishop to
F1 which is such a non-human move to
play because you've already think care
it you are preparing the castle but just
to show you as the engine really loves
it Bishop to F1 puts pressure on the A6
pawn and you can't just give it up
because then white starts advancing the
pawn uh If you defend it with something
like A5 which is really bad you you
should just give it up the engine says
that that's the best thing to do but if
you defend it then look at this Queens
side castles and now your A4 pawn and
these two pawns are creating a beautiful
Shield um uh towards the white king and
black will not be able to attack whereas
white will have all the time in the
world to to start pushing in the center
and on the king side let's say castle
and Bishop to B5 this just uh cements
your setup here and it's a really really
strong setup for white uh but okay here
uh castles by fedoruk and now Pawn to A5
this is of course now a possibility and
uh it's not a problem since White Castle
King Side Pawn to C3 and now B captures
and C3 B captures also offering the pawn
on C3 but ala doesn't want to waste time
if you capture it then you allow white
to develop um uh so so here Pawn to H4
right away starting an attack against
the white King Pawn to C4 defending the
pawn and now we have Castle's King side
uh we have Rook F to B1 uh and now
Bishop to G5 ala offers a trade of
Bishops and also he would like to get
his Queen into the game even at the cost
of the D6 pawn and it's a you know it's
it's hard not to take this Pawn so here
Bishop captures on G5 Queen captures and
just Queen captures on D6 now Sergey
creates a pass Pawn here and if he can
start pushing it it's going to be very
good for him uh so here Knight to C5 of
course stop in the pushing uh and also
preparing to REM maneuver the Knight to
E6 then to D4 and then maybe to F3 or E2
all depending on how Serge places his
pieces uh and here okay g h captures and
G3 is coming so you have to play G
captures and H4 we have Queen Capt sorry
not Queen captures Queen to F4 now uh if
you capture then you also give up D5
pawn and then it could be a little bit
tricky so here Rook to B5 that's the
that's the main move and it seems like
ala can just capture on e4 but the this
would sort of uh unwind into a draw for
example Bishop captures Queen captures
here Queen captures on E5 Queen captures
on H4 and now Queen to G3 white defends
against everything and um it's it's not
a problem you don't have something like
Rook to C6 to maybe get the Rook into
the game as the queen is hanging but
even if it wasn't of course it's
possible for white to just get the Rook
into the defense uh and here if let's
say some captures happen Rook captures
on C4 Queen captures on H4 Rook captures
Rook captures on A5 Rook captures on H3
it's equal material uh you know dead
draw so after Rook B5 Rook F to d8 was
played ala brings The Rook into the game
and also keeps the game alive Queen to
E7 and now Knight to E6 trying to get
that Knight to D4 so Rook to D5 stopping
that now you play Knight D4 of course
The Rook here is undefended so Rook to
E8 chasing the queen back and now uh
Queen all the way back to A3 and the
best thing to do here is to put the
queen on D6 because this prevents Knight
to D4 with a tactic if you try Knight to
D4 here just Rook captures and that's uh
going to be an issue uh but uh Queen to
A3 was played he wants to get the queen
into to G3 or F3 to help out with the
defense H but now ala can play Knight to
D4 but interestingly he doesn't he goes
for Rook captures on C4 and uh okay he
is getting very long on time he has 11
minutes on the clock um Sergey has 17
minutes uh we have Queen to G3 and uh on
this queen to G G3 move Serge spent
pretty much all of his time he's now
down to 5 minutes on the clock and we
are only still at move 28 so Rook to C1
with check of course alza wants to keep
the Queens on the board for the moment H
but not if uh Queen captures an effort
happens then he's happy to trade Queen
so here we have Rook to D1 stopping
check uh Rook to C2 and now Rook a to B1
again if you trade this is a better end
game for black as uh uh you have three
Pawn Islands also the the the H Pawn is
double the the bishop isn't all that
impressive here so instead after Rook to
C2 Rook 8 to B1 was played and now Rook
e to C8 alza doubles up on the C file
Queen captures on F4 uh going for the
queen trade Knight captures on F4 and
now comes a position where um Anish even
put it on Twitter and he said that with
Bishop to F1 white white is playing
excellent chess you know dominating the
Knight very nicely from F1 controlling
all of these squares uh but instead uh
Serge went too quickly for the pawn he
played Rook to B5 and it seems like
there's nothing wrong with this move but
there is actually something very wrong
with this move uh you tell me what feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for ala while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the the fork and the for for
fork those of you for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show uh it is
Knight to E2 with check of course
getting to C3 with Tempo is key and
that's just it Sergey blunder The
Exchange we have King to H2 and now
Knight to C3 uh with two minutes on the
clock anything is possible uh Rook to A1
was played but now all it is is just up
too much on material Knight captures on
B5 a captures on B5 and now Rook
captures on F2 we have King to G3 and
now Rook back to B2 and that's pretty
much it Rook captures on a five was
played yes you do have a pass Pawn but
now just Rook to C3 with check and he
was in this position un move 37 that
Sergey fedoruk resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
you you either move the king and then
you lose the bishop or you go here and
then a double attack and the bishop ends
the game you will take the bishop and
you are up a full rug then uh so yeah
very nicely done by Ala fedoruk really
held his own in there but he spent too
much time in a in in a critical
situation and he just missed a beautiful
Fork there so that means alza now has
farmed enough points to overtake Wesley
in the live ratings so we'll see what
happens tomorrow these are the live
ratings now you can see that ala
overtakes Wesley he's on 27 58.9 and
Wesley's on
27574 uh and that means that if any if
nothing changes then it will be ala fuja
who will qualify for the candidates
tournament via the uh rating U criteria
uh and uh by if not changes I mean if he
doesn't play a game maybe tomorrow's
game does not get played even though I
personally think it will uh but also Fe
they said that they will look into
things and that they will uh inspect if
everything was in order for this
tournament and will they rate it for uh
for the January rating list or not so
I've U listened to some discussion on
Twitter by some Arbiters and uh by the
looks of it there doesn't seem to be
anything why it why it wouldn't be rated
so uh if you know nothing changes ala
does qualify for the for the candidat
tournament via the rating place if
Wesley does not you know start farming
uh before New Year uh which is also
possible but as Wesley was so so much
against it I doubt that he will uh try
something like that uh so we'll see if
if the if game six even happens and uh
if it happens or not we'll see if Fay
will have anything to say about this but
for now it does seem like ala and GES
have qualified for the Fay candidates
tournament it's still also could change
so we'll see I'll keep you updated uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and a little bit of extra
info about the candidates tournament I
would like to thank Kenneth f j John
dugdale Ian Sterling Nikola V and Maximo
eer for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day